[Musique]
pk le major galopant grosic la panère
noire Bic le député
[Musique]
footbleurou le grand
maître co tête
d'oribor le
rebelle si hommes au sein d'un pays dans
la tourmente au cœur d'une équipe qui
fit rêver la planète football durant
toute la première moitié des années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
février 45 les Russes libèrent Budapest
mais à leur manière ne laissant pas
grand-chose debout sauf la statue de
saint gueller peut-être parce qu'il
avait déjà été
martyrisé malgré les camarades
opérateurs qui essaient de peindre en
blanc le désert de sang laissé par le
passage de l'Armée rouge le pays est
exang mais les enfants de la balle n'ont
rien oublié les enfants donc ont
toujours été amoureux du football leur
père aussi d'ailleurs vice-champion du
monde avant
guerre tous les dimanches à Budapest on
se masse dans ce vieux stade en bois du
hou pour y admirer les grandes idoles du
moment comme ce 23 mai 48 où la Hongrie
bat le voisin T 2 à 1 dans un stade
plein à
[Musique]
craquer
mais le sport est une chose trop
importante pour être laissé aux seuls
amateurs et ce ne sont pas des
chirubains qui inaugure dans le quartier
des anges le club des métallurgistes du
Vassas mais yanosadar son président
membre du bureau politique du parti
communiste
hongrois fidèle au directif des patrons
du communform il s'agit de ne rien
laisser au hasard pour Mathias raczi
premier secrétaire du parti afin
d'installer le paradis sur terre
[Musique]
mais une chose est le bonheur des
peuples dont le 70e anniversaire de
Staline est censé nous donner un
aperçu autre chose lesy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venir les communistes hongrois ont déjà
investi les principaux ministères
poussés par les Soviétiques qui
brandissent la menace occidentale et
créent une véritable hystérie de la
guerre le ministère de la Défense en
rajoute dans dans la militarisation de
son club omnisport le hwed dont il
cherche à étendre l'égémonie surtout
celle de sa section la plus populaire
celle du football où les parades
tiennent souvent lieu d'échauffement
avant
[Musique]
match deux amis d'enfance le Major
poukas et le capitaine Bojic soldat
d'opérette mais déjà footballeur
d'exception y mèneent la
danse
vleen mag
199 mikor kisp
horiken
h bu
unere silhette di celle de grossic jeune
gardien le premier vêtu de noir
peut-être parce qu'il voulait devenir
prêtre avant de revêtir la tunique de
Gaulle mais ce qui compte pour l'instant
dans le pays ce sont les derb enou
contre MTK ou plutôt armé contre police
car le ministère de la Défense et celui
de l'Intérieur tous deux aux mains des
communistes se doivent bien sûr d'avoir
aussi les deux clubs
P mieux qu'un championnat national som
un peu confidentiel 8 49 Hong renontre
l'Autriche contreassoci du vie
ireous regard
deer
national d'un merilleuxit offensif qui
les pousse toujours à
l'AT mal gardien autrichien ena dont un
de toute beauté tiré par
P
[Applaudissements]
mais malheur au joueurs qui voudrait
quitter le pays attiré par les sirènes
de l'étranger et ce n'est pas le
galonnais général Farcas ministre de la
Défense et président du houed qui
assiste à tous les matchs flanqués de
ses gardes du corps tapis dans la
pénombre qui le démentira ainsi Sandor
Souch arrière de l'équipe arrêté à la
frontière et condamné à
mort o je cache
BO
feren
far
far inspecteur des forure la deux il y a
donc tout lieu de faire attention à sa
tête de même l le terrible r prier secr
du parti et vice premier ministre se
montre un peu trop amical pour eux
soldat ou sportif c'est d'une même
soldatesque qu'il s'agit au printemps 52
c'est aux athlètes qui préparent les
jeux d'elsinki qu'il viennent rendre
visite visiblement impressionné par ses
muscles tout entier dévoué à la défense
du
[Musique]
socialisme
c'est
grandour glale h
jeux
Lam auquel le grand frère soviétique
participe pour la première
fois peu sensible aux faces officielles
les Suédois tenant du titre et prochains
adversaires des Magar font les oiseaux
de façon plus simple en D représentant
d'une démocratie avancée gagner ou bien
encore gagner tels sont les directifes
pour grossic le gardien et son
remplaçant
gu pour cois le buteur de
équipe boud équipier modèle exibor
l'éternel rebelle ils ne se le font pas
dire deux fois bien sûr pour ID couti et
les siens invaincu depuis 2 ans le match
contre ces gentils suédois ressemble
plus à un entraînement qu'à une
demi-finale olympique mais enfin le
score de 6 à0 leur ouvre la porte de la
finale
Seb
gustön
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Meg que bal au pied que PK surnommé oxy
le petit affronte son ami le géant bobek
même si le match semble aussi intense
dans les tribune qu'il est âpre sur le
terrain les Hongrois malgré les
récupérations constantes d'couti et les
boulets de canon de coxis ont du mal à
ouvrir la
[Applaudissements]
marque à la 71e minute en app de
mais cette fois-ci le petit major
galopant rapide comme la foudre efface
les armoires à glace de la défense
yougoslave et délivre enfin son équipe
suite d'une Rapsodie commencée 2 ans
plus tôt contre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'Autriche
pour ce premier sacre d'une équipe de
football hongroise dans un grand tournoi
international une jolie Miss Univers
pour le plus grand plaisir de PK et des
siens et pour la plus grande joie de
tous les Hongrois enfin pas tout à fait
encore car cette finale risqué devant
l'ennemi titiste ne fut jamais
retransmise en direct malgré les images
reconstitué après coup par la propagande
officielle
er
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
éte sámunkra mindenekőtt azért Volt
nagyon fontos ennek a tornának AZ elnyer
tehát AZ olimpiai bajnoki cím
megs e Volt a első
lehetőge a akkor
ú aranapak
hzetközibdar vág előemutatko
kéessen
Politi
mais pour
grossouti cois et les autres la
reconnaissancenational ce sera pour plus
tard maintenant ce sont 100000 personnes
à Budapest qui fê les médaill Magar
entre la Gare de l'Ouest et la place du
7 novembre et c'est tout un pays qui
[Musique]
jubile
[Applaudissements]
décidément tout cela tombe bien pour
rakzi qui au même moment devient premier
ministre sous l'œil un peu humide de
farcass son complice et les
applaudissements un peu plus obligés
diag le clairvoyant ministre de
[Applaudissements]
l'Agriculture
Minden előé
megat
fyelmez mise défini sur le pays
nombreuses victoires Olympi pour P et
les autres tout cela monte un peu à la
tête de tout le
monde une FO n pasoute grossum la
cigarette du maître des
lieux
chez FARC la sauterie tient plus du bal
de maling que des piqueenqu entre
[Musique]
camarades décidément on pourrait croire
à l'envol du pays avoir ses courses de
300 cm C sur les bords du lac Balaton
film façon Riviera où les motards du jou
à l'équipé sauvage même si la réalité
plus humble et si ceux qui courent à
pied sont plus nombreux que les grosses
cylindr
[Musique]
grossit bouille pushkas et leurs
coéquipiers du wed sont devenus les
modèles de cette jeunesse fleurant bon
le
socialisme une jeunesse qu'ils enchant
chaque fin de semaine comme se dit
dimanche en match amical contre le
rapide de Vienne le familier voisin
autrichien où coxis fait encore des
siennes sous le regard de leur bergers
galonné la collade entre joueurs et
sincère même si les sentiments les plus
nobles sont toujours recyclés au service
du régime fin 52 puskass rend compte de
sa participation au Congrès pour la paix
de Vienne devant le philosophe George
Lucas qui paraît un peu accablé devant
la hneur de son discours rappelant
bravement que le sport vaut mieux que la
guerre bien sûr tout cela n'est
qu'apparence et comme toujours le mot de
la fin reste aux apparat chic et surtout
au plus puissant d'entre
[Applaudissements]
eux quelques semaines plus tard un
simple coup de siffl arrête ses Litan zé
le cœur des lodateurs se fige sous les
masques dans une capitale hongroise où
tout s'immobilise le temps d'une minute
de silence celle où tout un pays censé
être bouleversé rend un dernier hommage
au petit père des peuples morts en ce
début mars
53 seulement qu'alappel racoszi a couru
ventre à terre à Moscou laissant
derrière lui les deux autres membres du
trium vira qui dirigent le pays le
funeste général farcass
Ernaud Guer l'homme à la chevelure
blanche qui avait armé les bras de
l'assassin de Trotski et indboulonnables
ministre du Plan c'est le sort de cette
sinistre Troya qui se joue dans le
panier de crab qui est devenu le
cremmelin et c'estrag communiste à
visage humain que vont revenir les
reines du gouvernement le brouillard a
coupé au couteau qui recouvrait la
Hongrie laisse place à une brume où
quelques rayons de soleil perceront
bientôt
le printemps hongrois éclaire toujours
cet automne 53 lorsque le 11 Magar sort
de ses frontières et soulève un coin du
rideau de fer aussi vrai que cette
équipe se confond avec l'histoire de son
pays comme la rivière coule
inéluctablement le long de la vallée
mais avant Wembley oou laend la plus
grande équipe du monde comme se
dessinent les Anglais eux-mêmes traversé
de la Manche oblige un détour par Paris
s'impose
ou plutôt par Paris il se gain où les
champions olympiques titre désire
rencontrer les gar de banour aussi
grands footballeur qu'ils sont modestes
les Hongrois ont toujours la sympathique
habitude de préparer chaque grande
rencontre contre quelques petites
équipes histoire de mieux entretenir
cette légèreté et cette suavité de jeu
qui fait leur
[Musique]
grâce il est vrai aussi g Le ment
n'oublie pas qu'il est membre du parti
et qu'il fut ouvrier à billancour avant
guerre et puis c'est avec plaisir que
l'on retrouve le camarade le Fran au
banquet d'après
[Musique]
match mais les choses sérieuses
commencent à Londres où fait découvrir à
ses hommes ce temple du football qui
Wembley devant un PC toujours
rur
[Musique]
19 kötöttem le
aolöőtitrval
hátzet nem
jel Volt min mom
hyemáoma pá nem a
pár ask him don't any Engish one word
him
n Not
Not than you
chez les inventeurs du football on a
décidément du mal à prendre ces types
tout à fait au sérieux ici on sait tout
de ce jeu même si l'entraînement paraît
un peu désuet les explications tactiques
limitées on n pas besoin non plus de
ballon pour s'entraîner à l'image des
stars ramse Matthews et
Mortensen il suffit de
sautiller côté hongrois on ne lâche pas
sa balle il y a la coxis parfaite
ambidextre mais lui ce sont ces deux
pieds qui font parler la poudre bogicle
député footballeur autodidacte accompli
et lumineuse arrière centrale
idcouti le grand maître stratège de
l'équipe mais aussi tireur émérite
Laurent le contrebandier avec lui rien
ne passe sauf ce qu'il se charge
lui-même de ramener d'une tournée à
l'étranger
xibor fantasquelier gauche que ses
coéquipiers appellent aussi le fou parce
que ses prouesses surprennent tout le
monde y compris parfois lui-même le
demiantau
g BL au merveilleux pied
[Musique]
gauch il n pas l'air vraiment inquiet
lorsquil pénètr dans le chaudron de
wemble même si le préparateur physique a
du mal à distinguer les quelques membres
de la délégation hongroise perdu au
milieu des000 spectateurs qui les
attendent pour une fois P semble sérieux
quand cette grande gueule paraî
concentrée on dirait qu'elle est timide
ce n'est pas le cas de Billy Wright le
capitaine anglais qui lui n'a pas l'air
[Musique]
inquiet bien sûr tout cela on ne le voit
pas à Budapest mais on l'entend cette
fois la radio est bien là même si comme
toujours on est anxieux quand on est
loin de ce qu'on aime sur place à voir
ses magiar se relaxer à leur façon avant
le coup d'envoi on se dit qu'on
naimerait pas être à la place des
Britanniques à Budapest les familles des
joueurs sont mis en scène comme ici chez
les bog il faut pas qu'il y ait le
moindre chîn manquant entre le ballon
qui pourra glisser dans les Anglais et
le parti pardon le pays entier comme
souent dans C ce sont les enants qui se
doivent de
donner la minute c'est la Jo che é le
prier du fils du père de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'p fidèle à son habitude il couti le
maître à jouer distribue magistralement
le jeu décidément on dirait qu'il joue
au volet et on oublie qu'ils ont des
pieds
h comme souvent aussi lorsquune équipe
domine elle est à la merci d'une
contre-attaque c'est ce qui se passe
quand 5 minutes plus tard morensen
égalise dans un stade en
[Applaudissements]
folie casselan tien il suffit pour les
Hongrois de passer la vitesse supérieure
à la 20e minute pushkass lalom devant
une caméra qui peine à le suivre même à
terre il joue de façon élégante passe à
couti qui d m fusilérique
[Applaudissements]
2 contrairement aux Anglais aller plus
vite pour les Hongrois ce n'est pas
courir mais plutôt faire courir le
ballon et le passer à quelqu'un que l'on
attendait
pasibor par exemple l' lier gauche qui
se retrouve comme par hasard à droite
face à P petit appel du pied vers
l'arrière et boulet de canon vers
l'avant pour marquer ce que d'cin vont
appeler le but du
siècle 3 à1 des spectateurs un peu
inquiets dans les tribunes et des
joueurs anglais de plus en plus
nerveux 4 minutes plus tard sur un coup
Fran de Bojic son ami d'enfance oxy
poukas qui décidément n'a de petit que
son surnom fait preuve d'une intuition
géniale par à gauche pour revenir à
droite juste le temps de dévier le coup
de Massu de bogi dans les buts du type
en chandail qui fait office de gardien
anglais 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à1 en moins de 20 minutes le sort en est
jeté tandis qu'à l'arrière grossic la
panthère noire se montre intraitable à
l'avant les Hongrois restent fidèles à
leur tactique qui va RVU
foall
pargan
que etis rement à hauteur des aers dès
lors ils seront qu attaants de pointe et
de milieux de terrain
[Musique]
avecő
játékstín mert ő elős
akkoralálkoel
Assal
[Musique]
amikor
[Applaudissements]
mat 6 à
3 il ne reste plus au gentlem des
tribunes d'honneur qu'à se montrer digne
de le réputation de
fa les Anglais n encore jamais ét B sur
le terrain par une équipe du continent
son Rais et hongrois encore et toujours
invaincu depuis 24 match en 3
Ansou Mang
cramp s'en étrangler
presque et maintenant c'est monsieur
poukas qui donne des leçons à une presse
soudainement devenue plus
[Musique]
humble cette fois le retour des héros se
fait ge l'est ils ont toujours leur
chapeau Suisse sur la tête façon thiler
américain revu par comité central mais
c'est une autre couronne qu'il ramène
car cette fois-ci contrairement à
helsink ce ne sont pas des équipes
amateur qu' on Fa
exploser bien sûr il y a encore et
toujours le salut obligé des
stacanoviste de service mais ce n'est
pas eu qui est venu voir et chérir le
peuple de Budapest mais bien les
meilleurs footballeurs du monde toute
catégorie
confondu
désormais tout le monde se les arrache
tandis que fidèle à leur habitude
pouchecass et les siens continuent de se
mesurer aussi bien à des
craqus qu'à des équipes de seconde zone
même si celles-ci ont parfois une notion
bien particulière du football comme ce
22 février 54 contre
l'Égypte
de retour sur le continent et en
Autriche il n'ont plus leur chapeau
Suisse sur la tête et leur complet
veston taillé carton bloc de l'Est a
fait place à des coles roulés plus Sants
certes les voyages restent un peu
organisés mais les autographes demandés
sont spontanés désormais et pas
seulement pour les enfants de Vienne ou
de Budapest mais pour ceux de l'Europe
entière les grandes idoles ce sont eux
mais si les enfants d'Autriche a demandé
des autographes ceux de Hongrie se
doivent aussi d'être édifiés façon
socialiste bien sûr parfois cela pose un
problème quand l'origine d'un joueur
laisse à désirer qu' cela ne tienne il
suffit qu'un membre de la famille sauve
les apparences une maman par exemple qui
serait une bonne stacanoviste veillante
au grains et aux performances de l'usine
de tuile où elle travaille et pour cela
un petit film
suffit deite
nem Nyon s HT m ét ember a felső vezet
HOG
Ré
[Musique]
certes la propagande est plus douce avec
NC le sanguinaire rzi mais les
apparences SAU sur la jolie petite
planète desou il s'agit maintenant de
montr aux Anglais que le gazon du ne
Stadium est aussi vert que CELI 22 ma 4
où les Britanniques reviennent pour leur
match
[Musique]
revanche accueilli par Lénine il
traverse très vite le Danube et son
histoire direction le stade du peuple où
il s'agit d'abord de leur montrer les
rutilantes réalisations du
régime même si les serviettes de bain
qu'on leur a fourni ne semblent pas les
combler elles font toujours bien dans un
décor qui semble visiblement plus
intéresser les caméramen que les joueurs
britanniques
euxmêmes cette fois encore poukas ne
semble pas vraiment inquiet avant la
rencontre ni tte le remplaçant de bouï
il découti non plus qui ne s'embarrasse
guerre de diététique et encore moins
xibor qui pour une fois communique bien
qu'à sa manière on fait semblant
d'écouter avec beaucoup d'intérêt la
leçon du coach Gustave Sebbes qui avec
les succès de son équipe se prend de
plus en plus pour le Napoléon du ballon
rond c'est P qui recu mais c'est Lantos
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tireutre
quê
geor se prend pour carouso c'est tot qui
marque avec son dos avant que xibor ne
signe du droit 5
à0 dans des plais à messieurs les
Anglais les bien d'orénavant devenu
invincible cette équipe d'or dont chaque
journaliste voudrait être le premier à
annoncer l'exploit à sa rédaction en
terre étrangère
mais avec cette équipe dont les défer
lentes ne s'arrêtent jamais il faudra
attendre encore un peu le temps qu'elle
inscrive un 7è but contre un seul aux
Anglais devant un peuple qui chavire
désormais la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vénère la presse du monde entier est
unanime pour faire des Hongrois grand
favori de la prochaine Coupe du Monde
épreuve reine censé tous les 4 ans sacré
la meilleure équipe de la planète et qui
cette année se déroule en Suisse en
effet on ne voit pas très bien qui
pourrait inquiéter ces hongrois
invaincus depuis maintenant 4 ans et qui
affronte au premier tour la Corée et
l'Allemagne seul les deux premiers de ce
groupe doivent être qualifiés pour le
tour suivant leurs adversaires les plus
coriasses les allemands semblent avoir
de la chance c'est vrai aussi qu'ils
sont cornaqués par une nur assez
spéciale un certain SIP Herberger qui
quitte rarement son
impère le jour du match les gradins du
stade de bal ne suffisent pas il faut
recourir à d'autres moyens tout le monde
veut voir les rois Magar tandis que
leurs adversaires décidément bien couvés
paraissent un peu poussins voire REPL il
est vrai que leur Nurs qui ne visent que
la seconde place du groupe a aligné une
équipe réserve mais dès le début
avir à la sour AC ge du CORG
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quour
décidément ils ont même du mal à bloquer
la balle ces Allemands et la
désinvolture de Lantos l luême l pagace
peut-être un peu à défut de jouer le
ballon reste donc pour les Allemands la
solution de
jouer quandich récidive cette fois le
capitaine Magar ne se relève
plus
si les Allemands triomphent ce n'est pas
bien sûr d'avoir étendu poukass pour le
compte parce que quelques jours plus
tard et avec beaucoup de chance ils
viennent d'éliminer une
corioslavie tandis que les Hongrois
rencontrre maintenant et désormais sans
pouchecass les artistes brésiliens tel
le grand Didi paraî de tous les
[Musique]
dons
dès le début le match est d'une grande
appreté mais il est dit que ce Brésil
éternel enfant gâté du football navait
pas encore très bien appris à perdre en
ce milieu des années 50 eux aussi
changent de registre coxis est
impitoyablement descendu durant tout le
match à ce petit jeu il est difficile
pour les Hongrois de jouer leur
partition habituelle de surcroix avec un
TO laiss et des Brésiliens qui ne ratent
pas non plus y des couti l'homme
orchestre le ton monte un arbitre
dépassé et c'est le très calme bogique
agressé par nilton Santos qui est
injustement expulsé avec son agresseur
heureusement et au grand â des
supporters brésiliens les chevilles de
coxis sont encore intactes à la fin du
match lorsque sur une attaque lancée par
cxis peut s'envoler et marquer ce 4è but
qui sonne la
[Musique]
délivrance tandis que grosic fait la
roue mais qui aur a été nerveusement
éprouvant ce match qui décidément ne
semble jamais finir saluer tristement
par un drapeau brésilien en Lambo et
qu'elle aura été longue 3 jours plus
tard cette demi-finale gagnée après
prolongation contre d'excellents
Uruguayens et combien aussi elle est
lourde pour Bojic et les siens cette
stratégie de leur coach pour qui chaque
match doit êtreoster et qui à ce titre
ne ménage jamais un titulaire en le
remplaçant pour un
match encore une fois ce sont les
Allemands qui jubilent car dans l'autre
demi-inale le équipe qui peu à peu'
écras deiblichiens 6
[Applaudissements]
à já
10óőá herberg hogy nem kegyetlenségz
ilyen
zóősatni föézett AZG AZT mondta most
esik aző ha várnap iSNI fog akkor mi
leszünk fölkben mert a magyarok nem
fogják elni
kondiciális
jtisberger JUET
ilénreux or de ber devant 65000
spectateurs et des photographes en folie
venus assister à cette finale où des
Hongrois bien qu'un peu moins piafant
que d'habitude doivent enfin être sacrés
B mis à part ils sont tous là les héros
de
wembleass aussi leur capitaine retrouvé
pour la circonstance tout cela est de
bon augure même si l'arbitre un certain
Monsieur Ling semble bizarrement vouloir
lui écraser la
main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les supporters allemands ahur des
poussins blancs qui alignent les
bvu de buts dans les 10 premières
minutes et un Herberger soucieux cela
pourrait suffire mais s compté sans la
ténacité allemande et surtout c'est
oublié la fragilité défensive de cette
équipe hongroise qui n'aime que
l'attaque avec un ballon raté par buansk
malheureusement dévié par Zakarias et
détourné par
Morlock dans les filet de
grossic c'est compté aussi sans
l'expérience voir la rouie d'un vieux
crabe comme Fritz Walter qui sait de
façon parfaitement interdite mine de
rien enrer une panthère noire un peu
moins
Fline pour permettre à marquer le but
[Applaudissements]
égalisateur et quand sur ce terrain
fange jeux les magiar passent la vitesse
supérieure coxis a du mal à prendre son
envol et même quand il y parvient c'est
le ballon qui se moque de Tête
[Musique]
d'Or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même le lumineux bogique d'habitude si
calme paraît désemparé ce jour semble
maudit et ce n'est plus un match que
l'on regarde mais une charge de la
Brigade Légère devant une défense
allemande maintenant retrouvée et puis
il y a toute cette boue qui convient
tellement peu à la Rapsodie mais dont
les chars allemands se
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moquent
3 à 2 pour l'Allemagne à 6 minutes de la
fin des Hongrois qui repartent toujours
avec les même Panach et des mains
allemandes qui remplacent maintenant
leurs pieds nul ne sera jamais en
l'absence d'image si à 3 minutes de la
fin sur une dernière passe d'couti à
pkas le but du capitaine hongrois était
vraiment entaché d'un h
[Musique]
jeu en refusant ce burempteur monsieur
Ling transforme calvaire et la joie
légitime des Allemands en
[Musique]
obscénité c'est le deutschlandales qui
va retentir dans le vieux stade du
wangdorf de Bern mais ce sont sans doute
d'autres paroles qui raésonn dans la
tête de
grossic pkas et de tous les Hongrois du
monde
celle d'un hymne national à la tonalité
plus mélancolique que triomphante où
l'on parle de celui que le malheur
accable depuis longtemps comme si ce
jour-là encore 11 hommes avaient voulu
rester jusqu'au bout fidèle à l'
[Musique]
magarde équipe qui avait pourtant tout
gagné ne sera jamais championne du monde
et cette coupe ne sera jamais la sienne
pour la Hongrie c'est un deuil national
et pour le régime un mythe qui s'écroule
celui selon lequel il n'y aurait une
équipe d'or que parce que les
communistes dirigent le
pays mais le parti n'est pas à un
trucage prês les actualités bricolent à
la frontière autrichienne un pseudo
retour joyeux des héros de Bern les
visages des joueurs ne semblent pas
vraiment radieux les figurant
spectateurs ont l'air unu poussif mais
enfa vaut mieux que lesesti déç de
Budapeste et la
[Musique]
tristeouretna min
aerkatt hazays AZT Leh Mani hogy
buapestencialista forralom volten
emberek ment ára
villamosatöntökörk ablakokatzátk
zőborba
Rákosi a akkor főök kö
meglátogattket de há
lbenosocsünk klönülza a SPC
tökéletes
[Musique]
boldogságenich c'est encore Nagi qui
danse certes mais c'est Ernaud Guer le
complice de rakozi qui trinque le clan
des réformateurs cède une nouvelle fois
la place à celui des conservateurs
tandis que Nji ne sait pas encore qu'en
disant adieu à cette petite paysane
c'est au peuple hongrois qu'il dit au
[Musique]
revoir dans un régime qui se rédit à
nouveau il faut trou quelques Bou
émissaire à la défaite de Bern rien de
plus simple il suffit par exemple
d'accuser le gardien gross
Iléa suff et PE l' de
[Musique]
l'usananö
hogyáellenem
kedely a
falt
oss à et tout naturellement cette équipe
qui toujours respire au rythme des
pulsation de son pays et de son histoire
entre à son tour en
turbulence remplaç ne sembl pas vraiment
à la hauteur l'équipe le fait moins
confiance et doit veiller au
grainependant laage qui veut que les
Allemands soi les champion du monde mais
les Hongrois les meilleurs SEM toujours
vra surtout oobre 4 lors de ce ce match
hongrie-autriche où les magiars
pulvérisent une équipe autrichienne
désarticulée devant tout un peuple qui a
[Applaudissements]
pardonné les Hongrois marquent toujours
et encore des avalanche de buts quatre
contre les Suédois ce 13 novembre 55
mais leur défense reste pour
et à quoi bon marquer tant de but si
c'est pour en encaisser à chaque fois
presque autant malgré un bog toujours
[Applaudissements]
omniprésent le 20 juin 56 sous des
trombes d'eau mauvais présage on reçoit
les vaillants camarades T et quand même
de là être si surpris inquiet
même voir
halluciné
pour la première fois depuis la guerre
la Hongrie est batue dans son temple du
NEP stadiion sil même tandis que les
visiteurs sont portés en
triomphe désormais le major galopant et
les siens ne sont plus les Invincibles
hongrois chaque équipe joue contre eux
le match de sa vie et rêve de les
épingler à son tableau de chasse même si
ce sont eux toujours qui ouvrent la
marque comme à Bruxelles par exemple
devant la famille royale d'abord
perplexe la Belgique encaisse certes 4
buts mais en marque 5 dont 4 et demi
encore une fois imputable à des erreurs
de la défense même la famille royale
enemperd son flegme
princier c'est le mérite de bukovi
nouvel entraîneur des Hongrois et
remplaçant baiss d'avoir rappelé grossic
pour ce match contre la Russie dans un
stade Lénine flambant neuf que les
magiar inaugurent devant 10000
spectateurs venus se rallier à la
casquette du Grand le ychine auquel tout
homo sovieticus qui se respecte rêve de
s'identifier et c'est contre ces
soviétiques qui ne leur avaient jamais
vraiment réussi que les magiars montrent
ce jourlà qu' ne sont pas seulement des
virtuoses mais qu'ils savent aussi quand
il le faut être des battants
c'est la victoire d'une équipe d'or
enfin retrouvé que signe la 7 minute et
comme il se doitibor le
Reb 2 septembre 56 pour la première fois
l'Our soviétique capitule mais sont
diffic à
oublier
[Musique]
cette victoire c'est la version joyeuse
d'un même événement la défaite du russe
dont 15 jours plus tard à Budapest la
réhabilitation de R et de ses coaccusés
serait la version digne certes r ancien
ministre de l'Intérieur de rakoszi et à
ce titre ordonnateur des grands procès
passés du régime avait été bourreau
avant d'être éliminé à son tour par ses
anciens complices mais P pour la pureté
du symbole et si aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de sa réhabilitation et de
ses secondes funérailles sa veuve côtoie
Guero son
bourreau c'est d'autre chose qu'il
s'agit le rassemblement de tout un
peuple contre la terreur et la dictature
des affidés de
Moscou et qu'importe désormais si le
lendemain 7 octobre les magiars gagnent
encore à colombe où ils rencontrent la
France
qu'importe les déboul du demi-français
Jean-Jacques Marcel qu'importe les
interventions de crossic et qu'importe
la descente du duo fontaine Piantoni qui
manque
d'égaliser pourtant nul ne sait encore
ici qu'on ne reverra plus jamais la
grande équipe de Hongrie et que cet au
revoir est un
adieu le 23 octobre une manifestation de
soutien au camarades polonais eux aussi
engagés dans une même demande de
libéralisation politique rassemble dans
les rues de Budapest plusieurs milliers
de manifestants pacifiques fidèle à son
habitude la propagande soviétique veut
faire croire qu'il s'agit de voyou les
torches à la main cherchant à mettre
Budapest à feu et à sang ce même soir
les premiers coups de feu éclatent aux
abords de la maison de la
[Musique]
radio le lendemain les combats sont
encore
sporadiques et dès le 25 c'est
l'embrasement général dans le pays par
milliers on prend les armes au nom de la
liberté tandis que les émissaires
soviétiqu et leursbir font encore une
fois appel au populairire imragi pour
essayer de calmer le jeu mais il est
tard
désormais c'est sous les balles que les
enfants de Budapest continuent de jouer
au ballon au pied de quelques tristes
relique soviétique façon à chellem ou
vieux tank T34 des unités hongroises
rallié aux unur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 30 octobre aux abords de la place de
la République enfant de la balle et
insurgé attaque le siège du Parti
communiste de Budapest tandis que l'on
tente d'effacer les traces et les
archives de 10 années de
dictature conseil et comités
révolutionnair prolifèr dans des St des
baptisés qui retrouvent leur nom
d'avantgerre les joueurs sont désormais
en imp et les ont fait place au har des
comités révolutionnaires mais à défut
d'une équipe nationale désormais éclaté
P Lesens doivent partir pour d'autres
stades défendre les couleurs du toujours
qualifié en Coupe d'Europe des Clubs car
malgré la tourmente il s'agit encore une
fois pour le régime de sauver les
[Musique]
apparences
ang
paramentóün
já
Meg Meg kap
[Musique]
mind
cevemb ch55 de l'armus V éindre qu'ilent
contre révolutionnaire recouvriront
l'ultime appel désespéré d'imrenagi au
monde
occidental comme on anné plusutôt en
février 45 quand l'armée rouge vous
libère à l'aube le soir sous les étoiles
s par milliers que les cadavre se
[Musique]
compte quelques jours plus tard à Paris
la poignée de main entre les deux
capitaines est un peu longue les
circonstances et les photographes
l'exigent ce 25 novembre où poursuivant
sa tournée et sa préparation en vue du
match de Bilbao le hwed rencontre le
Racing Club de Paris et pourtant elle
joue toujours aussi bien cette équipe de
hwed à se demander s'il ne s'agit pas de
simple réflexes
conditionné en effet qui sont-ils Cees
commandant poukass ses capitaines Boji
coxis et leurs hommes les portes drapeau
brassard noir d'un peuple écrasé sous
les chars des mercenaires confortant la
bonne conscience d'un Occident
impuissant les fantômes dérisoires d'une
équipe d'or a jamais englouti que les
projecteurs du parc chercheraient
vainement à ressuscité pour un soir ou
bien encore des déserteurs voire des
trêtres ayant abandonné le cœur de leurs
frères
[Musique]
il est loin le serment conquérant de 52
et c'est un cœur Lugu qui s'est envolé
pour melbour et s jeux comme souvent ce
sont les plus démunis qui rest tis que
du avec les devises enaiss lors de leur
tournée ESS de faire venir leur
[Musique]
famille
à son tour récupère sa femme tandis que
P soulag ser enfin dans ses bras sa
petite an d'autres ont moins de
chance malgré les dollars donn à
quelques passeur douteux attendil
toujours sa femme l'atmosphère n'est pas
vraiment propice ce match contre
[Musique]
Bilbao
et puis il y a ces journalistes souvent
un peu charonniard sans parler de ses
intermédiaires verreux mandatés par les
grands clubs d'Europe qui tous rêvent
d'engager ces types qui n'ont que leurs
vestes sur la peau mais de l'or dans les
jambes les brumes des Flandres sont
aussi opaques que le brouillard du parc
ce 20 décembre 56 où le H wed joue son
match retour à Bruxelles contre Bilbao à
l'allé les Magar ont perdu de justesse
32 chez S basquees où il est quasiment
impossible gagner à la 55e minute alors
que les deux équipes sont à égalité
Farago se jette avec l'énergie du
désespoir dans les jambe de GZA et doit
être
[Musique]
évacuéibor lui-même blessé le remplace
et par deux fois boîte en bas en est
réduit à aller chercher tristement le
ballon au fond de ses
filets Farago revient décidément il est
dit que ses hongrois ne seront jamais
des footballeurs comme les autres après
2 mois d'rance sur tous les terrains
d'Europe ils se lancent encore crânement
à l'attaque ivre de fatigue et titubant
mais égalisant et ratant de peu la
qualification non il n'étit pas des
déserteurs non il n'était pas des
mercenaires ni des aventuriers et encore
moins des traîtres il n'était que
d'immenses footballeurs faisant leur
métier jusqu'au bout pour simplement
survivre et se montrer digne de leur
peuple martyrisé
[Musique]
à Budapest où la révolution a été
définitivement écrasée un climat morose
règne et le sport n'existe plus les
matchs ressemblent plutôt à des Vals
tristes c'est pourtant là maintenant
qu'ils sont éliminés que leur fédération
toujours reconnu par les instance
internationale du football qui ne rêve
que de statut C leur demande de
revenir d'ailleurs là-bas à l'ouest
surtout à vide de sensation fortes de
bonne conscience on les regarde avec
moins de
[Musique]
passion à 1000 an dans un stade sans
Sirot à moitié vide ils sont pourtant
toujours là en ce début 57 avec leur
éternel bouquet de
fleurs sur le terrain ils sont 11
présents mais peu seront élus seul les
grandes vedettes intéressent les clubs
occidentaux ainsi les autes à qui ne
propose rien doivent-ils rentrer tel ce
bon Bou bientôt suivi par d'autres
grossic par exemple qui toujours
sentimental rentrera par peur de ne plus
jamais revoir son pays et les
[Musique]
siens seul reste le roi Puskas coxis
xibor et quelques jeunes espoirs qui
n'ont rien à perdre à l'automne 57 pk
est toujours
obá baráts
mlem hogy
FA
sous le célèbre maillot blanc et à côté
de Di Stefano le divin chauve pendant de
nombreuses années encore poukas va faire
les délices des supporters
madrilenes coxis lui aura moins de
chance engagé avec son ami xibor par
Barcelone grand rival du Réal celui qui
fut Tête d'Or et le meilleur buteur de
la dernière Coupe du monde conna pas la
réussite éclatante de P il y a des exils
qui tuent plus srement que des balles de
kalashnikovis Me en pleine déprime sans
avoir jamais revu la Hongrie un pays que
décidément personne ne saait
[Musique]
oubli même pasibor le plus contestataire
de
[Musique]
tous
sij
le pays est toujours sous le jou lorsque
gust l'éternel homme du parti et geor
Don le rôle ne fut gure glorieux pendant
la Révolution ramè accord avec les
autorités l'enfant prodigue PCH P le
temps d'un match et histoire de montrer
aussi que 56 est déjà
[Applaudissements]
loin d'abord tous ceux et celles qui ne
l'ont pas oublié et qu'il n'a pas oublié
et maintenant qu'il embrasse ses frères
en football c'est leur jeunesse retrouvé
quand
banskii grossic g et les
autres
[Applaudissements]
certes il ne fut pas toujours radieux ce
temps passé c'était celui du sang versé
par l'Armée rouge celui des jaes et des
pendu de raczi mais pour tous c'était
aussi celui de leur enfance celui de
leur jeunesse celui de leur vie d'hommes
et de femmes d'avant la vieillesse des
soleils d'été ou des ciels d'orage ils
acclamaient tous pkas et les siens au
milieu des has de stade en folie
souvenir déjà lointain mais que le
football toujours rappelle comme
maintenant dans un Stadium comble où les
quelques survivants de l'équipe d'or
vieilli mais toujours chéri reviennent
pour un après-midi sur le théâtre de
leurs
[Applaudissements]
exploits
et lorsqu'autour de 100000 spectateurs
s'apprêtent à entonner l'hyne national
ce n'est plus un peuple que le malheur à
câ depuis longtemps qui se recueille
mais 100000 personnes qui pensent à ce
bonheur retrouvver et peut-être aussi à
une liberté qui déjà se dessine
symbolisée par ce retour de poukas aussi
vrai que cette équipe toujours épousa le
destin de son pays l' déplais au tenant
du Sportium du peuple c'est plus que
cela le football et c'est pourquoi vous
tous le major
galopant la panthère noire Laurent le
brigand
ID couti le maître buzanski le rock
Lantos le bon géant Zacharias le
timide xibor le rebelle bogic le
lumineux
toi le généreux boudail et toi Tête d'Or
nous ne vous oublierons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais
[Musique]